we mentioned the patriots and cam newton
he'll be back today
for their first real practice of the
week they're playing the broncos on
sunday the makeup game from last week
this was going to be the patriots buy
they had to reschedule a total of seven
games to make this fit
because this wasn't supposed to be
denver's bye week but cam will be back
today
there have been no new positives the
clarence beak
crop report has come back clean all week
for the patriots since the
glitch over the weekend with byron
coward so
cam newton ready to go by all
appearances stefan gilmore should be
able to come back as well at least
before the game he hasn't
quite yet made it to that 10-day window
when you can return if you're
asymptomatic even if you still test
positive
you can still come back after 10 days if
you're asymptomatic
so gilmore could be back soon newton
definitely can be back it's been 13 days
since yeah
there chris and yeah and uh you know the
patriots at two and two
uh after playing some tough teams and
losing a couple of games that most teams
would have lost like against seattle and
kansas city
they're in a position now to to try to
to start putting win on top of win on
top of win yeah let's see where it goes
because you're right i mean there are
two losses or
impressive losses if there's such a
thing i mean where you know they went up
to seattle and it was one play
and then kansas city they outplayed the
chiefs without cam newton
until the game just fell apart and brian
hoyer just you know went to stupidville
there and some of the decisions he made
um so i you know mike i'm i'm
actually like maybe i missed this and
you could explain it to me and maybe the
audience did too but
i i was shocked i didn't know if i even
realized they were
shut down at that facility that was all
because of the coward thing and all of
that just to be extra precautious there
what was
i i don't even i thought they were back
in there a little bit that caught me by
surprise yesterday when i read that
yeah i think it's a combination of the
league's protocols and also the patriots
preferences and you've got some players
on that team like jason mccourty who was
very outspoken over the weekend
about whether the nfl and the nfl pa
really care about player health in this
regard or whether they just care about
getting the games in so it's been
kind of a delicate balance between
league and team and the team's players
to figure out the right way to proceed
but yeah here we are yesterday would
have been the primary
initial practice day in advance of the
preparations for the broncos but you
know they had some of it last week
getting ready for what was going to be
the monday night game against denver so
they'll be ready to go whether it's via
zoom whether it's on the practice field
they're going to have their plan
and you know the bill belichick players
can be trusted to run that plan
and with cam newton they're going to be
in a much better spot than they were
with brian hoyer or jared stidham
against the chiefs 10 days ago so
they're back today
pending the outcome of the daily
clarence speaks covet 19 crop report
which typically pops up at some point
between 7 30
and 8 a.m clarence b eastern i like how
you've injected that into the show this
week
clarence beaks hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports